das was ich ja irgendwie komisch finde
ist die man hat so ein kran bohrer der
mit magie angetrieben wird
ja den hat der mann kann durch seine
portale gehen und dann ist man bei dem
akkubohrer und der steht im arsch der
welt die könnte man theoretisch einfach
klauen
er wolle machen
du machst das meine ich habe das noch
nicht zurück herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge von mega projekt
zusammen mit dünner leute ja und ich
wollte produktiv sein also ich war etwas
war niemand ich habe letzten folge für
alle hey davon von redit ich hab ihn nur
sachen geschenkt und was ist das zuviel
nacht ist der baum von dem du sprach der
der standen auf der brücke und multivac
machen aber der baum gehen und was heißt
eigentlich hin was ist eigentlich komme
führen für einen winter chips da meine
diamant
zur schaustellung am eingang des
gebäudes hat er jetzt gemacht weil er
denkt dass es jetzt vintage weil ich
dass er anfang des projektes gemacht
habe so ein hipster alter hat er hat den
zweck der ja aber ich bin ein audi ein
ein original gangster und orit samurai
age bin ich ja da bin ich bin coni hat
den trend setter also irgendwann sondern
rein wollten wir wollten einfach ein
bisschen vergessen es ist dein haus weg
das war voll schön wie das ist einfach
weg gemacht dass das einzige was du
nachts sich vorher brücke erreicht dass
ein schönes haus durch das ist einfach
ab blatt würde ich jetzt nicht sagen
aber ich würde schon sagen warum reisten
einfache maschinen habe ich vertrauen
in meiningen turtle hier und muss als
beck einfach traumhaft das abgerissen
weil ich da einfach jetzt eine halle
bauen wollte mich auf technik und so
ganz konzentrieren wollte das schaffst
du ähnlich ich habe ja doch aber ich
hatte ja derzeit keine zeit ist mich
auch wieder im urlaub dann und dann dann
habe ich zeit aber hält bereits doch
nett ist doch einfach das ist doch
einfach unter dem haus in diesen
meisterträumen denn technik kreis machen
können und oberirdisch da machst denn
wer eine lagerhalle bauen möchte jetzt
geberseite hier bleib hier so dass
was machst du so kann ich nachvollziehen
alter muss man etwa nur selber neu
kräften gestoppt oder ist es nervig mit
dem name selber weil halt immer die
energie verliert geht würdest du sagen
damit klar ja ich weiß ja nicht kräfte
mir auch mal ein
das ist die beste waffe die skipper
dieser bessere ich glaube dass die
besten und verbrauchte extrem viel
energie egal eigentlich hollo bollo
altona damit schlagen schon gestört
nein leider nicht doch halt machen
quali umbringen juni im bundestag
gestorben weil die energie von dem king
das ist natürlich blöd wie viel energie
kommt herein herein kommen zehn
millionen jedoch schnell verbraucht
selber hat 40.000 mann ist auch für
schnell verbrauchen da muss man in
meinem leppek mit teils leppek
funktioniert aber nur wenn man das
elektrische jetpack er wenn man das
erhalt auf den slot hat und wenn man
auch im slot hat kann man kann nicht
gleichzeitig oder back on thames mit
body aber das ist volker k
dann muss man das auch ein schauen
das
na ja immer nur
bla bla bla bla im urzustand dabei haben
und dann immer wenn du musik machst du
schon rechtsweg sei man wieder richtig
dann geht das sogar fünf wird ja bei mir
fehlt da hinten zaun eines jobs mit
zukunft sagt und das meiste einklang mit
dieser energie verloren einfach mal so
ja ja denn er wollte mich ein bisschen
an energien führen nein ich wollte da
wird dann eher wieder geklaut das voll
unsicher hier eine currywurst noch nie
geklaut
mai neu aufbauen das war eine gute idee
aber erstmal muss ich meinen charakter
nano lasers elberding bauen das was ich
irgendwie komisch finde ist die man hat
so ein kran bohrer der mit energie
angetrieben wird
ja den hat der mann kann sich seine
portale gehen und dann ist man bei dem
akkubohrer den vormarsch der welt die
könnte man theoretisch einfach klauen
jawohl wir machen gerade das ist ja
erlaubt einfach weiß aber gar nicht mehr
funktioniert doch ich schaue mir zum
beispiel dafür hat marin auf jeden fall
schon mal erst schlafen ich hatte angst
mein nachbar simon verantwortung die man
war der der als expert sachen geklaut
worden war der das am lautesten betonte
dass das in ordnung sei
die arbeit wird wahrscheinlich übrigens
gerettet wenn ich das jetzt mache egal
ob deine verantwortung
aber egal dafür bin ich weitergekommen
ok oh ich kann mit der mensch irgendwie
sich ich bin moralische unterstützung
ich weiß auch gar nicht wenn ich jetzt
eingestellt ich glaube nicht
ok ich komme zu dir wo muss ich hin nach
unten oder nach hause 760 meter entfernt
scheiße dass das doch noch unter seinem
grundstück
wenn ich richtig würde nicht macht muss
er noch mal nach hause
doch näher kommenden enders von simon da
rein in das portal neben seinem bei
seinem haus war wo betreten verboten
steht wieder einfach rider dass alles
gut dass ich immer alles ist größer
langen wild bist normal egal was los
ich komme ich zu meiner portal das ist
in der luft so da kommt rein
ich dachte das ist oben in seinem haus
da muss erst mal durch aber dennoch eine
andere
portugal soll jetzt du dir wieder zu dem
was oben in seinem haus ist zudem was
oben in seinem haus ist dadurch dann
bist du bei mir
jetzt kommt einfach gehen ja gut guck
mal da ist vorteil da müssen wir noch
ganz viele kritiker und welche leben
nicht kaputtmachen
die kripo hatte mit mir zusammen gold
zudem müssen wir hin
dem portal entspringen wir einfach dahin
allein ist es woanders ist einfach hier
das egal ob eder nicht durch den schon
durch nach einem kompass auf das ist
kacke beim zurückkommen fast auf wieso
ich bin hier oben zurückgekommen blaue
portal
dann bin ich in seinem haus ganz vieles
borner der hat ja ich weiß nicht woher
hast nicht eine portable hohe kräfte
schwer man ja ich habe ihn dafür anders
an gekostet also zeichnung zeugs
kassiert und so
alter was hat das portugal wohl auch
energie unendlich darf das einmal
benutzen
ich wette du verlierst das war schwierig
weil ihr das nicht möchte einmal auch so
richtig zu machen
ja ich weiß wie das geht aber ich mir
ali damit die metzinger benutzen
natürlich geht das bei dir auch sehe du
machst kaputt junge ich mach nix mit
auch so ein ding im alter ist das meine
ich hab das noch aber will ich zurück
ich bin dadurch geflogen und dann war es
auf einmal weg jetzt ist geht halt nicht
ewig und ist die ganze welt weg du
kannst es nicht überall machen wenn er
nichts ist dahinter kommst oder nicht
halt das war knapp
dank maschinen
das ist so anfangs kacke weiß ja ich
merke schon dass da noch ein bett box ja
deswegen nicht nur überhaupt noch nicht
so viel da gemacht wird was ja keine
wertvollen und guckt mal cable
ja und warum hast du dich wissen
verstehen die ist die folgen online
wurde ein haus kaputt macht aber ich war
mit brockens man wir waren betrunken
jungen brauchten geld ja ich merke da
schon das war die dümmste entscheidung
einer ganzen laufzeit im megaphon
man sieht wird dein von ich das einzige
was man hat das ist doch jung ist und
sich durch alter dass dieser alle seine
wohnung kaputt macht und nichts mehr
ich will halt auch viel einfacher eine
lagerhalle bauen das finde ich ihnen wie
viel besser als wenn ich jetzt ein
hausbau wo ich eh nicht drin bin talal
du bist ein merkwürdiger typ lukas ja
jetzt hilfe da weiß ich was ich ja
wieder eine craybas könnt ihr sagen dann
eher allgemein so was du es an meiner
stelle machen würdest jetzt sagt nicht
bauen aus wohnhaus bauen
ich will erst applaus bei uns merken
aber dass er gut gemacht hast ändert
sich ja die voraussetzung der wird dort
aus dem haus waren aber ich weiß du
willst es nicht ist anschließend wie das
aus und ich gehe zur option b über die
total cup ist aber klar in welche
technischen geräte und viele sachen
verbrauch dieses mal noch nicht hast
also ich würde zum beispiel den körper
wenn wir die quelle wieder geklaut wie
sie sind hier so viele pilze kühl
die credits werden doch die von
minecraft experte von wem sie die ganzen
pilz küche
das ist dem msi experten seine sachen
alle wie man das loch wo ist das loch
das eine loch auf seinem grundstück
agata wiese macht man so ein grundstück
wo man alles dann unter dem ring so ein
loch ist wo macht nicht aus aber warum
machte das also das ist glaub die auch
dahin dass ich das mache ich halt noch
wenigstens oberirdisch und cool gemacht
aber dann
dann müsst ihr das auch oben irgend ein
bisschen cooler gestalten finde ich
keine frage sieht gut aus aber es muss
richtig gut aus findet er sich und
richtig cool aus aber da muss da oben
hat so einen coolen dann muss er den
zauber sich weg machen so weißt du im
zaun so weg macht das redstone energie
kobalt nikon dass das sind pipes die
energie transportieren
das kriegst du bist viel zu brav wären
damit dann fick dich alter ich habe
durch die zeit mich mit den ganzen
dingen zu beschäftigen
ich meine wenn ich jetzt noch gar keine
ahnung von gar nichts hasst dann wieder
reinholen und sagt ich will viele
technik sachen machen dass das dauert
ewig technik ist halt intensiv bisher
mancher des postwegs zeit da musst du so
hausmann wenn du und nicht so technisch
sachen ja und jetzt möchte ich mir eine
lagerhalle bauen bzw
nicht nur alle sondern sonne art abdach
mit mit yello labs sind so was alles um
dann mache ich danach drei anderen
technik wenn ich mich damit beschäftigt
habe also ich würde anfangen atomreaktor
auf kleinsten alter über haushalt ich
weiß das selbst gar nicht so viel man
ich würde echt der kleinen irgendwo
hinstellen aber da brauchst du damit
wären die kurve wenn die sache nicht
geklaut werden soll warum hat das
feuerrote aber ich das ganze hier
abgestellt habe wenn man sich da wenn
man was soll ich sagen wenn du die krone
technik macht dann kommt die teams
liegen halt da wo die query ist können
also geklaut werden ist also voll
riskant meister weist das hat aber alles
immer noch mit mit energie angetrieben
angetrieben mcrae muss mit einer gern
gesehen werden oder was war die frage ja
und weiter ja und wenn es erst dann
werden kannst du halt deine sachen hause
transportieren dann geht ihr
eingeleiteten fallen nicht im
zweifelsfall nicht verloren
nur die energieversorgung hier auch
teuer ist lv solarpanel zum beispiel du
kannst zum beispiel richtig viele
solarpanels man braucht die energie ja
gut gelaufen ist gute 512 braust durch
den hv solarpanel darunter macht keinen
sinn
danke für deine hilfe
ich weiß nicht was diese sachen halt
mache ich aber selbst nur eine quarry
und sonst nicht so viel technik
schnickschnack aber du hast zum beispiel
unglaublich viele parks oder heiße total
simpel mit einem pipeline transportiert
oder mit den ganz
in vielen papst ja ich hab nicht so
extrem wird es aber einfach nur
transportwege sozusagen transportwege
und das macht aber nur sinn wenn du wo
irgendwo ganz weit her kommen zum
beispiel von der prärie ich würde das
geld als erstes meine ganze so ein
automatisches sortiersystem bauen so
sehr als logisch diese steht die eltern
achim i nicht ändern es auf meinem
grundstück nenne ich mal kurz rein gehen
und wir würden noch nicht gekillt weiß
irgendjemand kaputt gemacht habe dass
das auf meinem grundstück so viel
zerstört würde das wohl die motivation
für mich gekillt ist ja das habe ich mir
auch gedacht also zumindest denk ich mir
das komplette query weil jeder der mit
seiner carey hatte gegen die wie kaputt
gegangen bei mir nicht der deckel des
lärms und siehst du das aber nicht man
in köln das ist eine unit der produktion
mad ab ob die unterschiede zwischen den
ganzen kabeln hier also das ding ist die
goldenen kabel sind einfach transport
kabel aber die beschleunigen alles als
es geht am club durch schneller und die
kabel stone die hier die da geht es also
langsam durch wie du hier siehst
ansonsten die gleich die diese holz
pipes wer aber auf dem platz stehe
die muss man benutzen wenn man was aus
einer maschine raus sieht das ist die
hier dran weil die muss es hier
ausziehen und die muss und das ding hier
ist dran um das um hier das super nanny
dieser redstone motor hier
er macht nur dass die items ausgezogen
werden aus dem recycler also aus der
maschine hier so der report quasi das
kabel genau das ist ausgezogen wird
und die sind noch ein pieks die sorgen
nun dafür dass die items nur eine
bestimmte richtung gehen
zu was recycle der
das cobblestone er recycelt halt einfach
nur paris denn die werden hier
automatisch erzeugt in innen in drei
verschiedenen geräten und die kommunalen
recycler werden halt scrap ist
rausgeflogen kommt hier weiter und geht
hier rein in den master und wenn das
klappt drin ist dann produzierte er
zusammen mit recht die mit kras viel
strom
ich hab da hinten mv solargenerator an
anderthalb hv solar teile und woher die
ganzen es dafür von der krimi ja zum
teil hatte ich deine steht doch locker
irgendwo am arsch der welt
ich habe man gar keine nein ist extrem
einfach ich brauche die arbeit auch ein
ganz wenig strom ein bisschen halt nur
langsamer ich würde sagen also man
sollte schon 2 lv solinger dafür machen
gut wo sich denn dein rezept das rezept
du kannst so rohstoff dafür von mir
bekommen du brauchst ein spielparadies
net du brauchst du noch viel eisen nimm
dir doch mal 36 eisen und bei stax
körper raus doppelzimmer ein bisschen
weiter
und rät zum brauchst du auch fähig die
direkt aus der direkt importiert die
items oder der direkt der bringt die
items genau alles was meine quelle
produziert hat kam halt hier raus
einfach das ist hier das ist das alles
in den kisten ihr das mikrofon aus rama
kommt da nicht raus wo er setzt du
kannst du dir auch noch nehmen hier in
der kisd redstone ihr sonst kann sie
auch ein paar snacks aus nehmen was du
brauchst und es kommt damit ist braucht
halt alles im [ __ ] damit um unfaire
stromversorgung und die creme ist
einfach richtig weit weg machen also
macht den portaner so lauf ganz weit weg
im portalbereich portugal nein ich mal
ein netter partei geht ja auch dann
musst du ja was ist man aber wohl
zugeben
wofür aber auch so das rezept für die
credit habe ich gesucht habe ich aber
nicht gefunden aber kanzler meter machen
wie gehe ich mit dem jupiter um kommt
man da wiki nach yuma du kannst damit
fast als mann du kannst damit auch ihren
und kopper und alles fernseher ausmachen
hier hast du noch 16 kilometer liegt
hier auf dem tisch
was sind das für lampen eigentlich ist
das white fixe willst es 30 meter noch
bei mir bekommen das gesehen was noch
aussteht
aber damit ganz ganz viele sachen mann
und ich habe hier noch was und zwar
stecke riesen hast du noch ein bisschen
was wäre ich ganz einfach zumachen
drucksaal einfach drauf so und dann
query siehst du das ist unrichtig
einfach zu machen
die gassen aber wenn ich versuche finde
ich die nähe unten drin
mit q er ist bei mir finde ich die a 100
weiter zittern
jaja finde ich nicht kann gar nicht sein
dass dabei q2 der buchstabe dritte
buchstabe a comic dem fuß mach einfach
cool dass wenn ich kein gebe sehe ich
sie schon
und wenn du nicht siehst du da gar nicht
dass ich so ganz vielen du keine kranz
viel aber keine query circa eine halbe
seite aber keine query dann guckt
einfach auf der energie nach weniger
deswegen ich verstehe ich warum hier
keine curry finde dass woche noch
umzingelt werden so dass murray so immer
falsch installiert so dass keine anderen
aber die ist halt einfach zu machen und
dann brauchst du halt nur aus der poppen
halt nach oben raus die ganzen items
wieder abbaut und muss an die seiten
mussten stromversorgung machen das alles
nur strom versorgen kann
und oben aus alten kisten leitsystem
ranmachen das heißt du machst einfach
papst antreibt sind ganz einfach an
damit ihr glas außenrum kappel stone
normal ich habe nicht so gut wie beim
wiki was du machst in dem in die mitte
ein glas und rechts und links daneben
machst du da bist oder gold endlich die
zahnräder nein das ist für die pipes
auch für die party und die passt einfach
oben aus der krise herausführen
aber die um die querung müssen doch gut
die quellen ein das ist jetzt was um die
fertige quellen nicht beim crafting
immer erst mal kehrt für meine folge und
dann sehen was gleich nochmal ich werde
nochmal meine quelle werde ich gleich
noch mal an
wir sehen uns dann morgen wieder fehlen
hast du schon hat und eigentlich nichts
mal schauen
fail